[Music]
how does one navigate the fears of
judgment as
in the society by not putting other
people on a pedestal
i just don't value anybody's opinion
over mine none nobody
i don't need their validation or
permission or permission
yeah you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me
first off i want to say thank you for
accepting mine white
in a very unconventional way on twitter
shooting my shot
i learned that from you of course you
keep saying this uh for years
and also want to extend a warm shout out
to your team
lou maher haley for making this happen
so if you're listening
thank you everybody uh i want to kick us
off straight to the
to the topic that we both you know have
been jamming on just before getting it
started
so the the idea of v friends
big fan been watching the space what was
the origin
or the genesis of the idea do you
remember the day of the conversation
that sparked
this in your brain you know it's a long
journey right if you look back
at all my garage sale videos if you look
at
the things i've talked about with
collectibles
um there's a lot of things that the
references i make to 80s cartoons and
nostalgia even my
fascination with wrestling character
development
there's a lot of things that went into
it but the aha moment
in in december and january there was a
lot of smoke
around nfps for me personally right and
then the aha moment in february was like
oh this is really happening happening
and uh i got very very serious about it
and what was really interesting was
there was a moment it was on a saturday
night in late january early february
where i was like
i'm i'm living this like
this is this is what i'm gonna do this
is what i'm going to do
and i'm going to get very involved in
nfts and then very quickly right behind
that was
what i normally do which is i'm going to
get my hands dirty right
so what ended up happening was
i knew that i had to do a project just
like i knew i had to do a project with
wine library tv in 2006.
and just like i knew i had to do a
project in 1997 with winelibrary.com
and wines that's right but empathy wines
was something i
i've done a lot of projects but both
winelibrary.com and wine library tv
and building garyvee and
buildingwinelibrary.com were
much bigger because they were my
reaction to there's something huge going
on
and let me be a student by being a
practitioner
and so that's what happened here oh my
god nfts is happening let me do v
friends which was really just a
recalibration of something i was working
on two years ago
called workplace warriors were which
were characters
that i was going to make into little
shelf toys right and desk toys
so that people could think about
optimism or kindness
or patience during their work days right
so
that's what happened there um
yes so it just was eureka and then a
hundred days later
it launches so for from that saturday
to the launch and the the post launch
energy and excitement in the community
like how's the journey been and what's
one
uh favorite story or a highlight that
you can think of that you were surprised
by
the journey's been remarkable it's uh an
incredible
you know 100 day journey for me you know
probably from february 13th to may 12th
is exactly the actual dates um
and i
will never forget it it's one of the it
will absolutely be a substantial moment
in my career i know that to be true
today
um you know i think you know it's funny
where my brain went the adversity
comes to mind you know that first hour
of launching on the 12th after one week
delay
and knowing that the there was a glitch
in the meta mask
gas and knowing that was gonna
turn people off the website was down
that was going to turn people off and
i'm running a dutch auction
right so that hurt the prices for sure
uh which was fine um
you know a highlight was the first one
to resell
a couple you know a week ago half maybe
four days ago
the first person to resell their that
was super exciting to me an open seas i
think an open c yeah
um so that's interesting uh you know to
me
um
[Music]
this community that i've built on
discord is out of control
that is going to be something but really
it's about the things to come it's
knowing that i've got um
a ton of things brewing
in the this is like the beginning of the
rest of my life right
i am going to build these characters
with the same vigor
that i use to build up my own personal
brand
i want to ask when it's all said and
done
what do you hope to accomplish with this
project what is the legacy
of v friends that you hope to paint over
decades
i hope that these characters scale my
mission to
teach personality traits that i believe
in
accountability kindness
ambition patience empathy
so i'd like to leave a mark you know why
not
why not try to be an impactful human
being
why not and uh i think the way i can do
that is through my communication
capabilities and i think i penetrate
people in a way that's unique
i uh i have come to realize that in in
my 30s
uh and early 40s and now i want to scale
that
because what i the way i talk
may work for you but it may not work for
your aunt or your niece and
or for your buddy john and i think about
that i know as a matter of fact i'm
quite aware
that for 30 percent of people 20 of
people it's instant
turn off instead of the other way a
little too much
too aggressive you know people feel like
my conviction and passion sometimes
comes across
as egotistical or as a know-it-all and
i'm empathetic to that feedback i
respect it
i also know that is the furthest thing
from my intent and
um and i'm incredibly passionate to
develop
these characters to continue my journey
of pushing
good human attributes and that's what
i'm going to do
gary i don't know if you remember you
probably got like a million code tweets
that day but i
i equate it to walt disney
of the nft era and i it sounds of course
like a hyper bully or a competitor
what i meant there was is the real
impact
will uncover 2035 2045
yeah that's right of the characters
because that's right i think what
what's interesting there is that you're
sort of almost removing yourself
from the message and the attributes
and and the values of what you what you
believe in are the message
because the characters and the drawings
are not you know uh
not necessarily just it's not just
garyvee in different outfits
right i think that's what i love about
it it's not it's not your face with
different outfits
it's kind of like we're disney when you
think about disney at star wars and
everything and you're like
it's the jedi it's it's the story that's
right
of who went on an adventure and what's
funny is historically walt disney vince
mcmahon
george lucas were always people that i
felt
more interested in than
being you know a famous person right
right even though those people had
notoriety
they were you know they were definitely
different than tom cruise
or hulk hogan right or mickey mouse
right
and so i um i almost feel like my
journey is going to be a little bit one
of backwards i you know i think it's
there's a very
i love interacting with people and i'll
never shy away from that
but i you know look my my behavior
proved it i didn't go to hollywood i
didn't want to be on the food network
or qvc i just became a me
an executor of the median that was
emerging with
youtube and social media i believe
that's about to happen with my nfts
exactly you know as as just a fan as
another executor as another builder in
the space
i think you laid the foundation and uh
was it tom billy who said that he's
incredibly jealous and i think that's
how a lot of us felt
uh a lot i mean everybody who's whoever
they're in the career arc they felt that
okay this was a great case study
in public and you owned it and also the
launch day and
the the stuff that happened after the
launch day again goes back to
owning it and uh people are actually
remarkably kinder than you think gary
right i think people don't give
people enough credit that like despite
all the glitches i think
the discord is buzzing and everybody
overall felt walking away like this was
amazing
because because the intent was there i
think a lot of times
leaders that was the lesson in that for
a lot of people that i hope people took
away which is
look there was a lot of things that
happened that weren't necessarily quote
unquote
on my fault on my fingertips but i
hired i was part of and i think
accountability is powerful and and
you know i don't want to tweet delaying
this
sorry you know we made it you know it's
not fun
but those are micro missteps in the long
run yeah yeah that's you know a week
later here with 35 million dollars
in in the friends sold peop people have
long forgotten that i got pushed a week
and that the first hour was clunky
i love it love it um so it brings me to
what's important for consumers and
buyers to keep in mind with regards to
nfts we're
just this is a meta question not just v
friends yep
what is what is something that people
need to keep in mind i know there is a
lot of smoke now there's a lot of hype
but what's something that's important to
keep in mind as a buyer as a consumer
as a buyer that 98 of these projects
will probably fail
i mean you know that is um
that's that's kind of um sorrowing right
like you know kind of like the early.com
that's right as you've heard me probably
repeat over and over and over
98 of those stocks failed right but
amazon and ebay did not right and to me
my focus is to make the friends amazon
you know i want it to be the project
from this era
on the flip side it's an incredible time
to dabble with point one eath or things
that nature because there's some
real diamonds you know there's plenty of
things on open sea right now at 0.18
that are destined to be 40.
many i actually think more than people
think
um so that's exciting i also think that
um
that the macro is here to stay and every
small business influencer podcaster like
yourself
needs to say kp saying themselves like
you know
could i put out 10 nfts and sell them
for 0.18
i was thinking about putting out like a
building public nft you know for the
first 10 listeners or something you know
i think you should i'll tell you why you
charge 0.1 or even less
you know you don't have to charge the
kind of like i wanted to go big
so you know mine was very premium i also
have outrageous levels of expenses
yeah okay yeah i mean
this thing's gonna have 30 40 employees
and have incredible levels of expenses
but
i think um i think you should because
you should learn because i believe nfts
will be a
marketing protocol
and an asset for everyone
in the long term and i think the sooner
one tastes it
the quicker they can take advantage of
it
let me take a guess if you were
29 today in new jersey this project
would have been you and sasha
and the garage hacking it out together
with for 4.1 eth
and then maybe maybe offering a yearly
wine membership
that's right right isn't it 100
i love that um i love that so much about
you that hasn't changed
at all gary you know i'm such a big fan
i'm grateful for
your consistency in your character um
okay impact is a big word that comes to
mind when i think of you
impact over the years we touched on that
earlier legacy
how many people do you think have
impacted over the last two decades
of your life what makes you wake up
and do even more for them
that's a great question um a lot
and it's just it's it makes me emotional
to think about how many
hundreds of thousands which is just
staggering
you know definitely hundreds of
thousands i just
have gotten enough dms and emails to
feel confident that that's right
which is just profound yeah and is like
emotionally humbling to think about um
what what what makes me wake up is a
very
interesting blend of selfless and
selfish mixture
uh on the selfless side i feel
incredible gratitude to the talents i
was given
in mindset and communication which is
such a byproduct of who i am on the
selfish part
the more you give the more you get yeah
and so i really believe that
i just do i believe in the practicality
of karma
i don't think it's this weird thing
called karma i think it's when you do
nice things i mean look
look at this right you know this is like
i mean
when i tell you the eye rolling and
anxiety that i get from the people
around me when i have no time
none and have seven trillion
responsibilities i've been off the grid
for three weeks with me friends and now
i'm back this week at vaynerx
and the company needs me yeah and my
admins my chief of staff they look at a
meeting like this and like who the [ __ ]
is kp
why are you doing this you know like we
need you for this staffing meeting or
onboarding meeting or interview this
candidate like real [ __ ] not like hahaha
right but i can never change back to
your point earlier
that i just inherently know that i need
to keep giving deposits of
like your podcast now is forever changed
by my
appearance yeah you will be able to
leverage
many zero to one that's right
and i mean to your point it's it's
there's some things that are micro and
there's some things that are macro right
and then
to me i almost had a 95
um guess rate that you would say yes
wow you know why why that's
your dna yeah and i think that alone
puts you in a whole new stratosphere
among world leaders whatever like all
these people
and not to say that you don't value your
time as much you of course you do and
there's tons of people who
but that's why when i was talking to lou
i was like dude you don't know how much
this means and i gotta first send you
presents because you know
because that's those are the people who
see the effects of this but
to me it's it i've been waiting for a
decade
i moved to the us 2011 gary you've been
waiting for a decade
binge watching your content but not
really watching it just kind of like you
know
yeah only to consume but applying it
immediately putting it back into code no
code project site
projects and really like building myself
a career path and i'm like okay
i had a 95 percent certainty that he'll
say yes because that's that's your dna
and
and i had a hundred percent willingness
to take a no which is you know what you
heard from me there too
well i wanna i wanna definitely mention
this this question around
immigrants a lot of your fans are
immigrants a lot of you know people who
follow me are immigrants
your work on amplifying immigrants and
shining light on your childhood story
resonated so much for for years with me
and you know as i said i'm an immigrant
you grew up in modest conditions in
india
and and thanks to a magical scholarship
one person's decision in in 2011 that
i'm here in the us
grateful for every day every single day
in this imperfect country that we all
love dearly
what's a qualifying trait that you've
inherited
as an immigrant as a young immigrant
that you look up to even today
when you see us the next sasha the next
garry the next immigrant and say yeah
it's still there
uh i you chopped on the one transition i
was following you the whole way what was
the
beginning part of the question what's
the quality or a trade that you've
inherited
that you you have it in you and you see
in other immigrants
um perspective
on the opportunity i think one of the
things immigrants have a
massive advantage of is they know the
alternative
yeah my incredibly awesome epic
friends who were born in this country
even if they travel a lot
you don't taste it the same way you know
i came from communist russia my even
though i came when i was young
the first 15 years of my household even
though it was in america
was just unlimited conversations and
stories of just
treacherous yeah sadness you know people
dying in their 40s and 50s see
normal alcoholism because vodka
consumption in russia
suppression you know anti-semitism you
know
persecution jail time fear just a sheer
level of you know i don't think
i don't think a lot of americans realize
that so many people around the world
live in fear right you know um
judgment and you know and i think some
of our social unrest
in the us in the last decade has given
people a taste of it
but the deltas for all my for all the
friends who are listening right now
who are americans it's you know people
around the world
if you have the context like it's
amateur hour our unrest
you know compared to around the world so
um
that i i think because of that
my friend everything else flows the the
the inherent work ethic that comes along
with understanding the opportunity
the humility yeah you know people who
are electric engineers in one country
come here and
wash dishes and clean toilets
and we'll do it in a second right
because they're like well in four years
i can
right and so i think it's that macro
perspective of actual
opportunity actual opportunity right is
a huge driver
and so i see the i see it in the drive i
see it in the humility
and i see it in the gratitude and the
complete lack of ego it's that humility
that i look for a lot
right because it had to start over fresh
correct
okay so a key tenant of course your
story is a lesson you share you've
advocated for years and embodied
yourself document
don't create which uh you know i think
has metamorphosized in into
uh building public at least in the tech
circles and i've embodied that
and i want to unpack that a little bit
more
why do you think most people still
don't believe in document don't create
still don't get what makes them
skeptical about it where
are you what do you think that they're
still on the fence of
the concern of judgment
plain and simple plain and simple how
does one navigate how does one navigate
the fears of judgment as
in the society by not putting other
people on a pedestal
their opinion i just don't value
anybody's opinion over mine
none nobody nobody
that's the scary response i got um
classic
another thing gary actually you you
touched on perspective for
now real quick real quick yeah i think
that there's unlimited amounts of
people's
opinion who i respect who have more
expertise and strengths in many
categories than me
but not the thing that stops people
you're ugly
you're you're not smart you're wrong
about these
subjective opinions on my subjective
opinions
and once you once you get to that place
it's a lot easier
i respect people's differences
but i don't they're judgment of if i'm
good or not
i don't need their validation or
permission or permission
yeah what's one piece of advice
you would give the pre-pandemic garyvee
uh it would be more of a affirmation
because this is because what the
pandemic has done is completely affirmed
so many of my beliefs the the advice i
would say is
hey you know that hunch you have that
during adversity you'll be at your best
um but you're not a hundred percent sure
because it's been a long time since
you've had adversity and things have
been good
and when you were a kid and got 911 and
then
young when you got um the global pit
you know economy recession
and you didn't have as much to lose so
there's a percent of you that still
wonders
well this new version of you the 45 year
old version
because there's a lot more to lose will
he
be different hey good news gary
he's going to not only be not different
and completely be ready to be a wartime
general or a
captain during rough seas you're going
to see
an even stronger version of yourself i'm
uh incredibly
comfortable with the way emotionally
mentally
operationally as a leader as a human i
navigated
these 18 months and it's given me a lot
of um
validation for me with myself within
myself
and incredibly remarkably prepared for
the next
adversity there was once uh
a quote that i read it said something
like money magnifies you
adversity reveals you yeah
yeah i'm a big i'm a big believer that
adversity money and fame
all do pretty much the same thing which
is accelerates the truth
right and um uh
you know i also i'm very detached from
my own self
i when i hear the accolades
or the booing i you know i really do
feel like a lot of that has to do with
my parents
meaning i feel like when i get the
accolades
i see that as a compliment to tamar and
sasha vaynerchuk as
probably more than i see it as a
compliment to me and i think there's
something
in that that works that i've gotta
spend more time talking about it's very
interesting you
can you unpack that a little bit more
like is it
is it because you think that they've
done great work setting the foundation
of your
self belief and that i'm the byproduct
of them
their dna and their parenting and their
decisions
and so i kind of see my
success and cheering as an incredible
reflection
on them and and i really share
my success with them in a way that i
think
i've come to learn is far greater than a
lot of people around me
and so i wonder if that allows me to not
to your point change okay it's probably
the reason i can maintain a level of
humility
that i do it's also why i have such
thick skin
to the adversity it's almost like i'm
detached
from it
it's not my success is not my oxygen
um you're more than your accomplishments
as a matter of fact i would argue that
my accomplishments are not things that i
really even think about i think
the book the process like the game
what is essential about you gary the the
the gary vee that maybe a
95 of the audience don't necessarily get
to see or don't don't
don't know yet i'm incredibly
at peace
i can actually feel it folks i don't
know if you if anyone's
of course they're not on air but i can
feel it at the reason
i'm i'm i think most people can most
people confuse my high energy
for any level like i think people would
be flabbergasted by my levels of chill
it reminds me of steph curry
and the way he plays it feels like he's
having fun he's not in the game
in a video game but he's actually in
real life
having as much fun every moment and and
i think to the other point
of that comp is
it's all slow for me i feel like when i
watch staff and other great athletes
you can feel that the game is slow for
them yeah
and i think for me that's what's going
on with
life and you definitely business it's
it's just slow i love that
what is your message to our billion
public listeners and fans
that um if they can build a relationship
with time and realize they have a lot
more time
that they will have far less anxiety
and that using a sports analogy if
you're down by 13
going into the fourth quarter
and you win by four you've won by four
and a lot of people's fourth quarter in
a basketball reference and in life
reference
is really ages 55 to 80.
so i'd like to hear from everybody
that's under 40
what are they so upset about that they
haven't accomplished yet
you have more than half your life to do
it there was a saying that you once said
that i carried like a torch when i was
having dark days
for for years and that is you haven't
lost you're just early
yeah i believe in that [ __ ] i i believe
that people are just
you're just early in the process it lit
up my night scary
just many many many many days when i was
in dark places that were like feeling
self-doubt i needed to hear that i would
hear it over and over again
and wake back up and yeah it was a big
one for me it really hit a lot of people
i've been
very that you know you're gonna die yeah
i think really helped a lot of people
because
you know if that doesn't motivate you
right you've got this opportunity
i think um i believe it i think that's
the other thing that really resonates
for me
like what i say i believe to the [ __ ]
death and so i think that resonates and
that's what i'm focused on communicating
things that are true
to me and and um i believe are true to
others
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you